we're going to Las Vega and see you do
your Las Vegas
[Music]
okay I want to see all the things on the
show floor today what's a good creative
way to go around and see everything
there is to see at NAB alright I have an
idea for a game battle royale in public
and instead of using something like a
paintball gun or airsoft or squirt gun
or whatever it's the camera on your
phone so you have a group text messages
all the players in the game and the
first person to post a picture of
somebody gets to kill that person mmm
hug be photo unknown player convention
battle on grounds right okay last player
live wins we're gonna go in teams of two
no backs of heads pictures must include
at least one eyeball of my balls of the
target so what happens if you see
somebody in ICU and then you quick draw
if you quick draw somebody whoever gets
the picture posted first to the text
read together be next read wins since
are any be it's all camera technology
and they have a bunch of cameras here
with huge lenses that like can zoom in
across like basically to the moon if you
take a picture off an LCD screen it
counts XO high-powered scopes and
weaponry by just a picture off another
thing out of a cannon booth is just
gonna be a massacre yeah I'm gonna go to
the jib arm all the way up so the
cameras like 20 feet in the air I'm
going to search people with that
Southall is where it's at Southall is
where all the heavy guns are what counts
as I hit hit is just a picture of a
person that really has the person in it
and clues lately more than like three or
four pixels up there plays yeah yes by
possible it has to be easily
identifiable as that person yeah there's
any confusion as to who it is doesn't
count
Christians are not gonna play the first
game because we have uneven numbers but
he is gonna serve as a 1-up so if you're
eliminated but you send a photo of you
and Christian to the group chat before
the game is over is there a limit to
revive yes only one Carmichael Nick and
Jake are off again separate teams to be
out the DSLRs yeah we got embedded
cameramen with each squadron I want to
team up with Sam because Sam's stealthy
prepare to die everybody
all right Lex with me I'm wiggling right
now Michael and we're in let's do this
brother the team doesn't get eliminated
unless both people have been eliminated
so you could get a double kill well you
could you could snap two people on one
photo it doesn't make tactical sense
quit ups and you can't communicate so if
the embedded journalists get too far
away from their assignment they get
fired
we've establish the basic rules and at
this point the fewer rules the better
game starts - two minutes and I will
text them when it's time to go
really certain everyone here hates us
right now
no this worked very well let's go to the
cannon area it's just took this I don't
think anyone actually went there yet
yeah we can get some of the funny shots
us like using the huge now see
we're two men we're going to go to the
cannon booth and utilize some
high-powered lenses to see if we can
turn them Titan is about let's go this
way
let's go to the Sony booth head start
okay watch where you're walking
they're ruling at all
Hey
I'm sorry what's up there dad it's so
nice to meet you guys let's meet you too
yes yes
he reads tonight them from up here so
that's the screen right there you see
that yeah we'll be there
yeah game on game on see a parking tuned
in there
[Music]
during their
Chuchu
Jake you're dead what all right we gotta
play all right now I can take the sniper
post over to you should make up what
let's go get him dude will you be
revived don't Sam Sam let's go get him
before the game in will be revoked so
right now if they find me they can get
one more life otherwise Wren and
Carmichael versus Nick and Nico
happening right now just waiting for the
confirmed kills to come in dang dude
Nick and Nico just slaughtered Jake and
Sam so ordered them they're on the same
pedestal that we went to first right
away earlier yeah we're there not even
close to us right now
Dogen here here here you aim I'll take a
picture or vice versa thank you
Jake's gonna get revived though and he's
gonna shoot us did I'll ever eat
Asterius thank gosh Christian
you have to send it hold up hold up
Karthik Becky
[Music]
they snagged us they start the skin
oh no they sniped us with our own camera
we're here today in sunny Las Vegas
Nevada to enjoy the NAB Conference what
is that it's the National Association of
Broadcasters tradeshow that's put on
every year to show off new cameras new
tech new software a bunch of stuff that
we use and our friends from aperture
have brought us out to talk about lights
how we use them and to reveal a really
cool new one but thanks everybody for
coming out it's quite a crowd that we
have here it's really really
heartwarming you guys talk about through
message questions and hear his talks
means a lot the first year we were in LA
we're working on a low budget awesome
movie aim didn't make any money we lose
any money we didn't make any money the
next year we actually went into
freelance visual effects hey just a
little bit of money enough to pay the
rent and Samy actually saved up a little
bit of a button we saved up like three
or four months of a buffer like rent
money and
kind of stuff and he made the jump over
to YouTube and we got lucky and that we
had in collaborate with Freddy Freddy W
on Mario Kart video market real life and
if there is ever a recipe for viral
success it is Mario doing things in real
life on YouTube the other recipe Ament
success which no one knew about yet it
was Minecraft things in their life on
YouTube and so that's we've made a
buying craft in your life video at the
same time we made to Mario Cart real
life video and that kick-started our
channel and within 2 or 3 months of
doing that we were making enough air
rent buy our groceries and at that point
in time that's all you need it
alright so damage Inc we're eliminated
they got revived but the Niko snipe them
both right again so two teams left ran
and see Mike first Nick and Nico it's
been dead for a little bit so I'm
thinking there's a little cat-and-mouse
hide-and-seek game going on the group
chat has been dead for a few minutes
we got a steak I see on the outside but
we go to the outside and go to Canada
the the lens is at the Canon booth can
only face the center of the hall so if
we boarded the outside edge but that
pork wire is moving so we got to be
really careful I know this gives Brandon
I know them they're gonna be super
devious it's to prove it or run yeah cuz
they're probably already out here
flanking us right now what if we think
they're flank flank their flank what do
you think Nick or do you think they are
dude I don't know they could be anywhere
I don't think they were not vicinity or
they would have seen us but keep an eye
out
my spider-sense tingling here there's a
some more mounted turrets over there man
oh yeah are they lower high oh that's
good
we can get a jib on
don't see anyone clean it's clear for a
few clocks where are they we're sticking
out like a sore thumb hi this is it time
train race
I don't know dude I feel like there's
somewhere in here
we are
we are in the open we get it we get
we're Devin Supertramp is right there
yeah we're we're filming this game where
he got to snipe people with photos
because I did one yet
you know we've been on the defense yeah
we're like if you texted me but I'm like
have to be at B&H right now someone I
have to work with I know right use me as
a disguise seaside salmon cheek or death
its Nico and Nick so keep your eye out
for they were always dead to me the
whole I mean me too oh man has a gun I'm
doing wonderful that's crazy
Lorenz just sent me a text saying these
bravia
same as building a Sony booth but I
think it's a decoy
you burn the dangers of the cannon is
I don't know guys whatever you do you
know behind you really whatever you do
do not look behind you for digital if
you're watching they're right above no
stack up
it's quiet to play
well anyway you got a shape I want to
take up a title we'll see you guys good
luck
live long and prosper what kind that
wasn't a handshake so
he was right here what use right here Oh
God
area we need to do point but here's the
thing we just gave them all these heads
to go over there and now we're leaving
there yes let me just drop bait and
leave it Christian there's Christian go
see him he's right there in the middle
[Music]
you got my lens
hanging there
they're gonna flank us so hard right now
we need to move we need to miss go let's
go this way
lead the way move move move
who's faster who's faster who's faster
did you just got shot man it just got
shot I'm pretty sure I got in there
before you did
no wait what yeah I got you I beat you
red I guess so and see Mike win that
round because they got the kills before
the revised happen it's all about that
data cuz you got the picture of me at
the scene see Mike was over upload he
might was alive when they were both dead
at one point II my data killed me yeah
we totally sniped do that oh my god
that's a sweet head shot